MARKUS KLUTE:
Welcome back to 8.20.
In this section, we're going
to talk about cause and effect
and causality.
And we do this with
an example which
talks about the good
guys and the bad guys.
There's always good guys and
bad guys in the universe.
In this example,
those two groups,
they were fighting a war.
And after some very
long and grueling time,
they were able to
sign a peace treaty.
So this happens in this
story at year number 0.
So in year 0, a peace
treaty is signed.
And the good guys, they
go back to their families.
They go back home
to their planet.
There's a spacecraft,
which is able to go
with a velocity of 0.6
times the speed of light.
The bad guys.
That's the bad guys.
And so they develop a
faster-than-the-speed-of-light
spacecraft to follow
the good guys.
And they succeed with the
development of the spacecraft
after four years.
So they do.
They follow the good guys.
And in year number
5, the bad guys
attack and destroy
the good guys.
The challenge for you now
is to explain the story
and answer the
following question.
When and where does the attack
happen, from the good guys'
perspective?
And when did the bad guys
invent the spacecraft,
from the good guys' perspective?
You will see some surprising
results in this analysis.
So please stop the video
and try to work this out.
I recommend drawing a
space-time diagram in order
to get to a good picture of
what is actually happening here.
If you do this, you find
the space-time diagram
here for the bad guys.
So again, there's a number
of important events.
In year number 0, the
peace treaty is signed.
And then the good
guys, they start
traveling away at 0.6
times the speed of light.
So what you see here is a
world line of the good guys.
In year number 4, in
the reference frame
of the bad guys, they
developed a spacecraft,
and they keep following
the good guys.
And here in year number 5,
the attack actually happens.
So if you analyze this
for the good guys,
you find that the exposition,
the position of the attack,
is in their spacecraft.
So let's figure out whether
or not this is correct.
You find gamma and
xB minus v times tB.
If you put in the
numbers, you find,
luckily, the exposition
is equal to 0.
At what time did
this event happen?
Here, for the good guys, you
find gamma times tB minus v
over c xB.
And again, if you
put the numbers in,
the attack for the good guys
happens in year number 4.
But then the question
is, when did the bad guys
invent the spacecraft
in the reference
frame of the good guys?
And if you put in
the numbers, you
find the invention actually
happens in year number 5.
So the attack happens
before the spacecraft
is invented in the reference
frame of the good guys.
And this clearly
violates causality.
You cannot use a device which
is not invented yet unless you
travel faster than
the speed of light.
You travel in time.
All right.
I find this a really
funny and geeky example.
And the reason why this doesn't
work out, why it's geeky,
is that they travel faster
than the speed of light.
So let me conclude this
part of the section
here with a concept question.
We have an event A,
and ask ourselves,
can event A cause other events?
So event A might be the
invention of a spacecraft.
Can event A cause event C,
event D, or more than one event,
like B and C or B and D?
Note that the time access
here has units years
and the x-axis has
units light years.
Again, stop your video here.
Think about your answer.
Maybe you draw in the
space-time diagram
in order to find the answer.
And the answer, the correct
answer, is C. Only event C
can be caused, because
only C lies within what we
call the light cone of event A.
In order to impact, in
order to cause an effect
on any other event,
the message needs
to be traveling
with speed smaller
than the speed of light.
So that means that, in
order to reach event C,
we can design a
spacecraft, or we
can send a light beam to this
event or in this direction.
And then just wait a little
bit, in order to make any sort
of impact on event C. We cannot
travel faster than the speed
of light, which would be
necessary in order to reach
event D. And you can also
not go backwards in time,
this message is, in
order to reach event D.